errors can be coding errors made by the
programmer errors due to wrong input or
other unforeseen things I will be
discussing how to handle errors in Java
Script error handling is used most when
working with data from other sources or
user input since those can be unreliable
it is common to see error handling
associated with Ajax calls and
asynchronous code error handling uses
the keywords try catch finally and throw
the try statement lets you test a block
of code for errors the catch statement
lets you handle the error the throw
statement lets you create custom errors
and the finally statement lets you
execute code after try and catch
regardless of the result so let's see
some code okay here's the first part
we're going to try some code to see if
there's going to be any error and we're
going to console that log start of try
runs and then this part right here is
the error because there is nothing in
the program called unicycle and then
it's going to try to run some more code
here and then it's going to catch the
error and then we're going to have the
finally statement I'm going to run this
and then we'll talk about what's in the
logs here so start up try runs that's
right here and then it reached the error
so since the error was reached here it
never goes to this next statement once
the error is reached it goes straight to
the catch statement right down here it
says error has occurred reference air
unicycle is not defined at Penn Jas 14 3
so it we pass in an error object to the
catch statement and then I'm going to
console that log error has occurred and
then we console dot log erred dot stack
now dot stack is is when it's going to
show this part right here we can also do
without the dot stack where we just log
the air and if I run that you're going
to see this bar and this is
it's going to be used usually not all
browsers can handle the the dot staff so
when the error occurs JavaScript
generates an object containing the
details about it so so that's what this
error object is and it's going to have
two main properties name and message so
the name is the reference err right here
and then the message is unicycle is not
defined and then I also already show you
about getting the call stack then it's
going to go down to the finally
statement whether or not an error
happens we're going to always run the
code in the finally statement this is
always run and then at the end you can
see the execution continues so that's
just after the the try catch statement
is over it continues now for the try
catch to work the code must be runnable
in other words it should be valid
JavaScript it won't work if the syntax
is wrong like if I have a an opening
brace here and I don't have the ending
brace and then if I try to run that well
that's not going to work this is called
a parse time error while try-catch only
handles runtime errors so the code has
to be able to run so I'm just going to
delete that here and then run that and
we can actually see it run this time
there are many built-in errors that
already exist but you can also create
your own custom mater's with the throw
statement I'm going to talk about throw
errors in the context of a more
realistic use case for try catch
statements okay let's say you're going
to get data from a server often from a
server you get JSON data sometimes
through an ajax call but we're just
going to pretend like we got this data
from a server and then we're going to
try this let user equal jason par so
we're going to parse the data that we
got from the server and then if there is
no user name we're going to throw a new
syntax error and complete data no name
so let's say we're expecting the data
from the server to have a name but this
doesn't have a name so we're going to
throw a new syntax error and put
incomplete data no name now you can
actually throw a number or a string or
or a boolean but also you can create a
new air like a new syntax error or
a new heir and you can pass in the
message so syntax error is going to be
the name of the error and then this is
going to be the message of the error so
if I run that you'll see what I mean so
you can see down here we're going to
console that log JSON air and then we're
just going to log the message e dot
message so the message is incomplete
data no name the name of the air will be
syntax error so if we log the e that
name down here I run that you'll see
JSON err syntax error or we can just log
the entire thing and just do e and it's
going to say JSON err syntax error and
complete data no name so it got the JSON
air then it says the syntax error that's
the name of the air right here and then
it's going to have the message
incomplete data no name so in this code
if there was a name it would console
dialogue the name but there's not a name
as soon as it throws this error here
it's going to go to the catch statement
and that's when it logs the error
statement right here so that's the
basics of error handling in JavaScript
check the description for a link to more
information and also to the code used
thanks for watching my name is beau
Carnes don't forget to subscribe and
remember use your code for good